j'ai entendu tout aussi ya quelque chose
qui se trouve en bas à la cave les
autorités se trouvant à new york
nous avons besoin de vous d'acteur il y
avait un déficit en hémoglobine chez
toutes les victimes
que savez-vous pour l'instant c'est un
virus modifiés qui transforme l'adn
j'ai besoin que tu m
je sais plus ce que je suis donné je
suis toujours ton frère je vais trouver
un traitement l'homme que vous
connaissiez s'est volatilisé
mes amis et moi même ne sommes pas des
terroristes nous avons autant le droit
de vivre que vous aussi horrible que ça
vous semble
cette guerre est aujourd'hui nécessaire
la patrie du sens va triompher
l'infection se propage plus vite qu on
croyait tous ici
auld est sensé
je suis m je crois que je peux vous
souhaitez j'ai besoin de temps
vous nous rejoignez
qu'est ce qu'on va devenir
[Musique]
shi
for me voir dr je suis macho